welcome to a video about video editing
with blender today we're going to go
over speed controls
now as you can see i'm on blender 2.9
0.1
and first thing we're going to do is
just go to file new video editing
this gets us to our video editing
interface
now speed controls but before speed
controls you know what i'm going to do
i'm going to switch this output
and file format because this is just
something you need to know and no matter
what you do to your video if you don't
get this right you're not going to get a
correctly rendered result so
let's just go and change this file
format to ffmpeg
encoding and then change the audio to ac
and go ahead and set our output to where
we want it to
to render when we're all done all right
so let's go ahead and bring in a video
i'm going to do this with my file
explorer today so i've got this whole
folder just full of video
that i've uh recorded and stuff
[Music]
and yours may differ but i'm just going
to grab i don't know i don't even know
what this is this is about a 60
about a 60 megabyte file so i'm just
going to drag that in
[Music]
and of course you can use this area up
here to navigate to your video
and it's up to you to get your video in
how you want so this brought in a 60fps
video looks like this is
probably a some kind of tutorial i did
i'm just going to zoom out here in this
timeline and see
what kind of length we're working with
looks like it's about 10 minutes
and first off before we get into the
speed control stuff
i'm just going to click on this video
here this is the main video
and i'm going to see what the length of
it is i'm going to go to time
and see that the duration is 365.
i'm just going to copy this and set it
as the endpoint
that way we have a full length
here i'm going to click on the audio and
click on display waveform that way
we can see where there's audio going on
looks like it's pretty quiet audio
and now let's talk about the speed
controls
so this is the main crux of the video
if you have a part of your video that
you want to be nice and sped up
what you can do well there's a couple
ways to do this
i'm going to show you both ways i'm
going to show you the way that i usually
do it first
and i'm going to show you another way so
i'll do some speed up and slow down
of both ways so the first thing you want
to do is do a soft cut
there's a hard cut method and a soft cut
method i'm going to show you the soft
cut say i want to speed up
this section here from 30 seconds to one
minute
so i'll go to about 30 seconds and i'm
going to select
both the audio and the video and just
press k for a soft cut
then i'm going to go to about the one
minute section and press k again for a
soft cut
you note note that the video has to be
selected for it to cut has to be
outlined in this little orange
so say we want to speed up this clip
right here to be
way faster maybe 8x 4x whatever it may
be
so we've got it selected and what you do
next
is you go to this add effect strip speed
control
and also press shift a to get that same
menu and
so now that we have a speed control we
click on the speed control
and we'll look at the strip options over
here make sure this strip right here is
selected
and now what we're looking at here is
effect strip we see a multiply speed
this multiply speed has stretch input to
strip
length checked this does not work on
soft cuts so you have to uncheck this
and then you have to set the speed
factor to 1
and then you change this multiply speed
to what you want it to be
so let's just go with let's just go with
8x in this example so i'm going to put
8.
that is the first part done this will
now be 8x faster but the problem is
it's way too long because it's going to
play out the whole thing
to about whatever here and it'll it'll
be done so
the rest is just like it extending into
a video that you don't want to
so you have to divide the length of this
by eight
since we sped it up by eight so since
the multiply speed was eight
we're gonna go to this we're going to
click on the strip here
scroll down to where it says under time
you might have to uncollapse this
and look for the duration the duration
here is 1932
so we're just going to click on that
click on the end
part of it so that our little cursor is
at the end and
then press divide 8 enter
so that was just a slash 8 and it sets
it to 242.
you can also manually put in this number
so for example i'm going to bring up
a little python console here and i'm
just going to hit undo
to undo this duration thing real quick
so if it's 1932 oops it's 1932
you can literally do 1932 divided by
eight see what that result is
we get 241.5
so you could go manually put this in
here but it's just nice to be able to
do the math right there and it handles
it for you sets 242.
now what about the audio majority of the
time
people just cut the audio and put like a
little music or something
that's fine but if you want to leave the
audio and want it to speed up too
what you do is you click on the audio
and look for pitch you want to pitch it
the same amount you sped it up so since
we sped it up by eight
we want to pitch it by eight and this is
gonna make it sound chipmunky and super
fast
it doesn't display correctly on the
waveform this waveform is no longer
correct once you've pitched it
so what we want to do is just put this
to the same length we can press
g hold ctrl
and it will snap then we can just click
and let go
and there we go so now this little
section will be an 8x
and it'll be pitched with super chip
monkey sounds
usually what i do if i leave the audio
in is i lower the volume
to like half or so so that was an 8x
speed up but you know if you want to do
a different speed
you just use a different number other
than that eight so let's do a slow down
so let's say we have a section maybe
just a little section that we want to
slow down maybe an action scene or
something there's no action in this
particular video so it's not the
greatest example
but i'll do it anyway just for safe
example
so let's just take this little section
right here so it's already soft cut on
this side now i'm just going to soft cut
on this side over here so i'm going to
press k again
and now i have a section so i'm going to
click this video here
and once again add speed control shift a
extra speed control
this time we're going to do a slow down
we're once again
going to uncheck the stretch input to
strength strip length this does not work
on soft cuts i will say once again
if you try to use this you're going to
get all kinds of weird results that make
no sense so uncheck this
set the speed factor to 1 always speed
factor to 1.
multiply speed is now we want to slow
down so we're going to
this is going to be some kind of
fraction so if we want it to be quarter
speed well let's just say half speed
we'll put 0.5 so that would be half
speed if we wanted to be
quarter speed we put 2.25
and so on so you just set it as the
fraction of how much you want to slow
down if you don't slow down
or do even 0.1 for a tenth of the speed
i'm just going to stick with 0.5 for
this example so now that this is
half speed it needs to be extended
so let's do some i'm just going to box
like this and press
g box select press g grab it and i'm
going to move it up here so i have some
room
to work with it now needs to be twice as
long
since it's half speed otherwise it's
only going to show half the video
so you click on this here the video
strip
that you've modified go down to the
duration
and just put times 2
and that's because we have speed half
the speed so it needs to be twice as
long
if you did it a tenth then you need to
times it by 10.
all right and now with the audio click
on the audio usually you want to get rid
of it but if you want that slow moaning
or sound you can have that in here too
you just change this pitch
to the same fraction so
it would be 0.5 in this case and you
also want to extend it out
just click the end here press g
press control snap it to the end
now of course we probably want to move
this one out of the way and we'll put
this down
down here and i'll just put it right at
the end
there we go so now we've got a sped up
section a slowed down section
and i could play those back and you
would you would get them literally
so it's going to be a little bit of slow
playback but i'll just do it for sake of
example
it's gonna be super laggy
and the slow down section
okay so that's how you do speed up and
slow downs with soft cuts
and just real quick i'm just going to
add in a text
i'm going to press shift a text this
doesn't really have anything to do with
the speed up or slow down
i'm going to extend it out to the length
and i'm just going to put some text in
here that says
8x 8x
and i'm going to put two forward things
and make it larger just so that i don't
know it's just a way to kind of
show that the video is being sped up by
8x
a lot of times people just put something
like that on it for fast forward but you
can do what you want
but yeah you can overlay text and and
play around with it
and we can do the same thing for the
slowdown one this is
not once again nothing to do with really
slow down or speed up just something
that's
a little user friendly to do so on this
other one it's a slow down
we'll put a yes how you would write this
would be like 0.5 x
speed or half or however you want to
save
you know whatever works best for you
so that way you can kind of
show your user or whoever is watching
what the speed is if you want
totally optional just something i like
to do occasionally
uh most people just leave that out
though okay so let's do a section with
hard cuts
and this is where so let's just go to a
completely different section we'll go
down here
and i'm just going to pick an arbitrary
section and this time i'm going to press
shift k shift k does a hard cut
so i'm going to move this other one out
of the way
so with a hard cut you can't extend this
back
it'll be just like the paused version of
whatever it's coming to basically so
with the hard cut
it's a little different so we're going
to find the area where we want it to end
say right here select both of those
shift k for a hard cut so we've done a
hard cut
on both sides of this clip extending it
out won't work
it's just going to be the same video as
it ended or whatever it's gonna be like
freeze frame
and uh so let's put it back
so with hard cuts you do the same thing
you go to add
you go to effect strip you go to speed
control but now
you can do it the same way you can
uncheck this
use stretch input strip length stretch
to input strip length you can uncheck
that and do it the same way as you did
with the soft cut but now
since it's hard cuts you can also use
this stretch to input strip
length you can actually use that so
you can click the end of this shorten it
and it'll fit the whole thing in this
section so it'll be super fast you don't
know exactly what it is so it's really
hard to get the audio right maybe even
impossible
so i wouldn't recommend keeping the
audio if you do it this way
just delete it with the delete key but
now
you can get a super sped up section
that you've that fits to the length you
want and
if you extend it out once it's a hard
cut
so i'm stretching it way out and this is
yeah that's going really slow so you can
either stretch it out
or squash it down squash it down to
speed it up stretch it out slow it down
and that's how you do it with the
stretch to input strip length
on a hard cut so that's pretty much it
really guys
the soft cut method you can't use this
stretched input strip length the hard
cut method
you can that's the big differences let
me know if you have any questions
thanks for watching peace out you guys
[Music]
you